foreign
folks welcome to rational science
the only site on the internet that does
physics rationally
today we have a great day we're going to
be uh looking at some questions a couple
of questions and I'm going to answer at
the end of the show and we're going to
be looking at what
the holographic Universe what in the
world could that possibly be I have no
idea so if you came here to hear about
the holographic Universe you won't learn
much from me but we're going to let the
uh uh you know let it out from the
horse's mouth let the people who who
proposed the holographic Universe tell
us about it
anyways we're going to begin with our
Extinction segment and the only thing I
want to let you know is that I'm using a
different computer today so if I go a
little bit out of focus or something
I've had some problems here and there uh
just be aware that it could be due to
this different computer
anyways uh let's get on with our
Extinction segment and lately they've
been uh talking a lot about
extraterrestrials visiting us there was
a congressional hearing uh people saying
that um
you know that the government the U.S
government knows about it and keeping
all this information secret
and uh uh and all kinds of things uh
related it's it's been on the news and
uh there was this fella his name is uh
Abby lib or I guess I'm pronouncing his
name right
um and he's from Harvard he's a teacher
from Harvard and because he's at Harvard
he's a professor at you know in Harvard
he's given uh this big status so if he
says something about extraterrestrials
you know you got to listen to him
because he's a professor at the
University now I I have to caution uh uh
give you a word of caution that a lot of
um
physicists out there don't agree with
him okay and they dismiss him as a
crackpot but uh you know he's uh
published a book and he uh tries to get
the Extraterrestrial thing out into the
public
um so that people you know follow up on
uh these extraterrestrial things which I
guess in the back of his mind he
actually believes that you know
extraterrestrials have visited the Earth
or are visiting Earth or are watching us
or have something to do with us already
okay and again let me show you something
in a couple years ago he uh was one of
the persons involved with the with a
disc a an elongated disc of sorts uh
looks more like a rock like a just a
flattened out rock uh like an asteroid
but they claim that the because of the
orbit it comes from out of the solar
system and so this is Abby Le lib uh
talking about this uh asteroid called
something like uh Obama or something
like that okay so listen to him uh give
his uh
scientific speech here okay if I can get
this thing up there okay uh here it goes
listen carefully here goes
[Music]
a million miles
okay so uh that was his dissertation on
Obama or whatever that thing was called
and uh this is a
paper uh something he wrote he wrote a
book about it and I guess he was trying
to promote his book and this was an
article that came out uh once you know
and it says like this says uh it could
be just another surface layer above
spaceship this mama or whatever it was
called
uh that was torn apart it could be
something like a sort of space junk it's
just like walking on the beach most of
the time you see rocks or seashells but
every now and then you see a plastic
bottle that is artificially made it's a
very different type of evidence than in
the past it's like a message in a bottle
a physical object that we Trace that is
artificially produced and uh he's uh
this was a declaration to uh in in that
article again because he was
um writing he he was publishing a book
like five days after this article so he
was putting a little uh propaganda
behind it commercial
the significance of
is that it implies perhaps that we are
not alone that it was not naturally
produced that it was produced by a
technological
civilization meaning a technologically
Superior in Civilization that's what
he's implying right the moral of the
story is that even though we didn't get
enough evidence uh on this object to get
an image of it or to be sure that it's
artificial it is sufficiently intriguing
we should continue to search the sky for
similar objects okay so um he's one of
these uh fellows who was trained or led
to believe that science has to do with
experiments and observation and so uh
you look this guy and you see something
weird and you say oh okay uh that came
from outer space that came from another
planet another solar system you know
and you go in there and you try to
analyze it and reach your own
conclusions
it never occurred to him that maybe we
don't need to do any of that maybe we
can figure out in advance right whether
anyone from any planet where there's
human type life or human level
intelligence if they even have the
possibility
of coming to visit us you know and
that's where the issue is because if
they have no possibility you know we
shouldn't be looking for anything okay
if we if we by reasoning alone can
figure out that it's impossible for
living entities to travel interstellarly
then we don't need to look out for
anything out there for evidence of
extraterrestrials okay
and uh here uh he says the following
says scientists Deep dive for Aid in
life leaves his peers dubious a lot of
people don't agree with uh Abby a
Harvard astrophysicist says that
material recovered from the sea floor
could be from an extraterrestrial
spacecraft and this was more recently
and he says that little ball there that
they found somewhere in the Pacific
that's another clue you know that the
extraterrestrials uh have sent something
over to the Earth Dr lib uh LED an
expedition to retrieve fragments of the
fireball off the Western Pacific Sea
floor LED by identify the fireball as a
What technological Gadget with
artificial intelligence such as
discoveries may be the way scientists
find evidence of extraterrestrial life
and again this is not an issue of um of
evidence this is an issue of if you can
reason it through that it's impossible
to for someone to visit us or or that
it's impossible for any living entity to
travel interstellarly meaning from there
to here right then we don't have to
worry about evidence and it's these
people who think that science is about
evidence about producing evidence
evidence is used only to persuade people
that's what prosecutors use evidence for
to persuade the jury to convince them to
their side of the case it's got nothing
at all to do with science okay it's got
to do with religion we're convincing the
flock that's what it's got to do with
okay so these people have the wrong
notion of what the scientific method is
about and what science is about
here's another fella whose name is
Stevie Greer and he says the phone he
says aliens started making more visits
to Earth after the first atomic bomb why
does he say that because we have this
movie uh with uh Oppenheimer you know
it's Vietnam so he's gonna try to see if
he can fly with it and make some uh
propaganda for his own uh you know pet
peeves he says was detonated because
they're concerned that we're going to
destroy the planet a UFO expert has
claimed who's the UFO expert what's that
fellow over there Steve Greer who
reminded me of you know when he was
younger you know Mad Magazine anyways
our uh Dr Steven Greer they call him a
doctor I mean what kind of doctor is
this fellow I mean is he a dentist a
foot doctor what kind of doctor is he I
mean you have people like William Lane
Craig who's a doctor and went in
spirituality what kind of doctorate
degree is that's absolute nonsense and
this vows more or less than the the same
boat I mean if he's going to talk about
UFOs he calls himself an expert what
kind of doctor is he you know he did was
warm a seat in the University which
means that just because you have a PhD
does not does not automatically
translate into intelligence and he says
he continually says Dr Stephen Greer an
American ufologist who founded the
center blah blah blah right believes
there is extraterrestrial beings out
there who are light years ahead of us in
terms of Technology
so he believes it so so he he just puts
it beyond our reach he says oh they have
super intelligence they have all this
technology which is uh Way Beyond what
we can even imagine
and by doing so they they put it out of
your reads they don't even answer the
question what kind of Technology they
could have they just they have this
super intelligence the super technology
and because of that they can come here
and you know zip around the universe uh
wherever they want and uh so they have
all this technology to look at us or
even visit us if they wanted to
but he says despite being far from
advanced than us uh the development of
the first atomic bomb by Oppenheimer in
1945 a story recently told that uh you
know in the movie right gave aliens a
reason to come to Earth okay so this is
how they handle the this information why
did they even give this guy 10 cents a
little a little you know uh peace in in
a magazine
deserve the time of day I mean what does
he have to offer he's just gonna say
that there's all these intelligent
beings out there they have uh technology
that we cannot imagine you know it's
unimaginable technology and because of
that you know they gave all the yeah he
gives all this power to these et's and
because of that now he can get away with
saying yeah they can do anything they're
like God you know and so we Beauty
little humans you know we're here and we
have to live with whatever uh these
people determine
and it's got to do with subject matter
of today which is the holographic
Universe because a lot of people think
that that's got to do with uh you know
the aliens creating us in their
computers you know we're just a com
a character in a computer program you
know so people watch a lot of this
Hollywood stuff I guess that's where
they get their doctor's degree and then
they come out and they say oh I know uh
uh all the aliens you know they're
running around with spaceships and we
can't see them because they're so fast
and they've they're studying us
fortunately they don't kill us you know
I mean these people have no no business
being in the news at all but that's what
lately what we were having I guess we
run out of news so they have to bring
this subject up every now and then you
know every 10 years or whatever
okay here's um another fella
and uh his name is Dave grosh and Good
Old Navy he testified at the uh Congress
in Congress saying that the government
uh is hiding all this information from
us because all these aliens are invading
us and somehow uh us with our lower
technology we're able to capture one or
two or some parts of a spaceship and
because of that you know the government
you know keeps it under ramp so it's not
to scare I guess the people out there
so again why are these people even in
the news these people don't deserve the
time of day they don't deserve even they
have an opinion okay I mean if they want
to have an opinion yeah go to your
little uh seti Club you know search for
extraterrestrial intelligence and talk
about it over there but to be in the
news and to be pushed on the public
saying oh watch out you know the
Twilight Zone they're coming to get us
and they're already here and maybe
they'll capture you and take you to
another planet and why all this nonsense
what what is this about you know don't
we have anything more important to uh
consider you know to talk about
okay and uh a lot of this started with
this fellow uh it didn't really start
with him but he was the guy who really
gave it a big push his name was uh Eric
from Donegan a lot of you probably know
him and he came out with his book
Chariots of the Gods I think it was 68
or 69 thereabouts and um and yeah they
were talking a lot about the space uh
Program in those days and he put his
book in there to see if he could make
some money and he did make some money
because of this you know he was able to
publish his book and like you see there
he was saying that you know the um
uh you know those pictures that the uh
uh they had over there in Mexico uh they
had to do with uh actually what they
were representing was an astronaut you
know traveling on a ship and he told a
lot of fibs created some false
um
evidence you know he went to Peru in one
case and he got this ball and he was uh
put it in his book saying that was
extraterrestrial and it turns out it was
made by someone over there
and uh things of that nature they're
just trying to sell books you know on
this subject there is no chance
whatsoever of you know
um extraterrestrials coming here let
alone even in contacting us you know
because like I say you know the highest
intelligent possible in the entire
universe is the one the humans have
you know there can't be any higher
intelligence than us if anyone you know
God and Almighty himself came down and
sat beside us and explained to us
anything he wanted we would have the
intelligence to understand them now if
you haven't been blessed with
intelligence you think there's some
super intelligence out there all you can
do is complain to your mama maybe you
should sue her if we're you know making
you the way you are you know but we have
the highest intelligence possible in the
universe Mother Nature has run out of
blessings to give us
you know so this is it if you don't have
the intelligence I'm sorry uh complain
to your mother sue her whatever okay and
uh here let me give you a uh an example
here are the voyagers okay these are the
uh probes that are the farthest from
Earth uh today uh man-made probes and
here you have some numbers to give you
to put it in the proper uh perspective
you have uh 9.46 times 10 to the 12
kilometers is how much light travels in
one year okay that's 300 000 kilometers
per second times uh 31 million uh
seconds in a year okay Now Voyager two
uh is um travels at 17 kilometers per
second and in one year it travels 536
kilometers per year okay that's in in
536 kilometers a year and uh this uh
it's headed towards the Star by the name
of gliese and which is 17 light years
away and so how fast will it reach there
how much time will it take for a voyager
one to get there in fact not to it but
about 1.6 light years away from it but
it takes 300 000 years
and Voyager 2 is headed in a different
directions towards Sirius and it's going
to be far away from it's going to be
about 4.3 light years away when it goes
near serious okay and uh series is only
is 8.23 I'm sorry it's uh 8.7 uh light
years away and it would take Voyager 275
000 years for Voyager 2 to pass by
Sirius that's how slow these things are
going but if you look at it uh you know
these Pros are traveling about half the
speed that the Earth travels around the
Sun and so among the fastest speed that
um you know that we can manage so far
and people say well you know uh uh we're
gonna go faster in the future
well I don't know see a lot of this is
is used uh with uh gravitational assist
from the planet sometimes they send it
through to a planet like Mercury or or
usually outer planets like Mars or or
some big one like uh you know Jupiter or
whatever
and that gives it a gravitational assist
it throws it around and then kind of
slings it out okay that's the idea but
you know uh to think that we can travel
much much faster uh and
um even worse close to the speed of
light it's just irrational totally
irrational there's no way we can even
approximate the speed of light okay 300
000 kilometers per second we're talking
about 17 kilometers per second in
comparison so it gives you an idea you
know the the uh distances and the amount
of time are just prohibited and so to
think that we can ever go to the nearest
star let alone to visit some cousins out
there in some place of the universe it's
never going to happen it's just not
gonna happen at all
and which gives you an idea that maybe
NASA you know is working on the wrong
projects they're working on projects uh
for military purposes no problem there
you know that's got some benefit or or
for advancement of Technology but if
they're really working to put
settlements on Mars and later on in a
nearby star those projects should be
terminated no money should be spent on
that at all okay that's my five cents
worth on that
anyways um here's um uh Jules Verne
syndrome when I call Jules Verne
syndrome which is today's science
fiction becomes tomorrow's science
that's what people think
a lot of people suffer this syndrome
they say oh today we we can't but
tomorrow we can well the question is you
know can we do anything we want
but can we develop any type of
Technology we comes to our minds for
example you know can we travel through a
1D Wormhole to the 40 for another to
another 40 universe is that possible is
that even imaginable you know I'm trying
to throw 1D Wormhole or is there such a
thing as a 4D universe and so you know
when you when you consider these things
you got to look at you know what we're
trying to imagine here you know we're
doing a lot of fantasy which has nothing
to do with what Jules Verne uh did in in
the days of Jules Verne it was still
within the laws or the realm of physics
today these people are completely
outside of physics because they're
talking about abstract Concepts they're
going to be traveling through a 1D
concept called a wormhole which is not a
thing and uh and they're trying to reach
Another Universe which you know we have
to define the word Universe to find out
you know what they're talking about is
there another Universe out there if it
is does it share the same space that we
do and if we don't what stops that space
what what what barrier is there between
our space and their space so if we all
share the same space we're taught about
a single Universe you know there is no
second Universe out there the only thing
you can say is that there are another
lump or clump of matter out there and uh
and that we you know that uh
uh in a way you know it's separated from
our clump of matter which we could say
is our Clump is different than their
Clump we can't talk about universes
because Universe includes the word space
and hopefully we have the same space
throughout the Universe okay there's
only one space out there only one
Universe in that sense
okay so Jules Verne syndrome uh can we
think of anything we want uh well here's
another thing uh that you might want to
ponder when people say yeah we can do
anything we want we can invent anything
that comes to our minds Etc and is this
possible you know here you have uh the
Thinker you know saying that he's going
to talk someday with a real live Donald
Duck and Sylvester now is that possible
you know so all these people are uh
really going out into uh into a world of
fantasy and they take their fantasies
into put it into the real world
and yeah I can't imagine uh us going
through 1D wormholes I can't imagine us
talking to Donald Duck you know but some
of these people really think anything's
possible
you know that they can become a cartoon
character maybe you know because uh you
know there's uh so much technology out
there they get in uh bombarded by all
this stuff that's out there and then
they casually just extrapolate the uh
fantasy into the real world and they say
well Jules Verne you know he he thought
that a lot of the stuff wasn't possible
and here we are we went to the moon and
and we travel around the world in 80
Days and so on yeah that was within the
possibility within uh the realm of
physics this stuff's not even within the
realm of physics in fact all of quantum
mechanics and general relativity and
string theory none of that has anything
at all to do with physics the physical
interpretations are just garbage and the
math is irrelevant because they're
developing equations for stuff that has
no presence in real life I mean we have
no use for black holes and dark matter
and uh big bangs and all that stuff that
these people are researching and
developing equations for I mean what do
we need all that stuff for so they're
developing
equations for to ridiculous levels for
stuff that has no reality no no
Foundation no nothing to do with our
real lives
so what are these people doing you know
they call themselves physicists they're
mathematicians that's what they are
okay one person uh made a comment about
that he says I completely disagree with
your beliefs about aliens okay
uh there's a bunch of illegal areas over
there okay I was one of them I have met
quite a few Highly Educated people who
have said their presence is totally
obvious okay so we have intelligent
people saying that that it's obvious and
it's a done deal you know okay Stanton
Friedman blah blah blah shared me that
aliens are visiting us in a personal
discussion after his UFOs our real
lecture at our local University
1972 okay uh William Jinn from uh
Anaheim took frequent trips with uh
George blah blah okay the high desert to
observe UFO activity
okay so I gotta go to doesn't see I mean
you know I've been to Arizona and New
Mexico quite a bit and I I still have to
see a UFO you know a little flying
saucer with a great little green men you
know I never was stopped by any other I
was stopped by cops if anything but not
my little green men three friends and
iOS they're two craft doing extremely
high speed Maneuvers one evening
I mean you know
these people see more than there is
maybe they see a light in the sky they
take a picture of it say oh I found a
UFO yep what did you take a picture of a
little light you know there's all kinds
of stuff in the sky but to say that you
took a picture of a of a UFO meaning
extraterrestrial I mean when I talk
about UFO I mean only extraterrestrial
and the question is you know can you
tell an extraterrestrial one from one
main from U.S Air Force
I mean you know this is with us trying
to the type of questions you should ask
yourself
here's another fella and he says the
following he says um
says uh given that the place where we
live is in a rotating globe
I like his introduction this one made my
day okay then there is no reason why
there cannot be uh Lands Beyond
Antarctica
[Laughter]
they may be a few thousand miles away
from the shore of Antarctica if you keep
traveling south at which point aliens
are almost certain to visit here
what can I tell you yeah you got these
people out there who actually believe
you know uh in this case a flat Earth
says that there are Lands Beyond
Antarctica well uh yeah you you'll roll
around the earth end up in the North
Pole if you go completely around uh no
there are no Lands Beyond Antarctica and
hopefully
um you know the aliens don't you don't
find an alien coming in your way from
you know from one of those lands now uh
impossible it's simply impossible to
travel interstellarly and I've talked
about that a little bit in the past and
essentially I'm saying that it's
impossible to travel through what I call
the um linear regime which is the uh
Separation The Great separation between
the bird's beak created by the ropes
that come out of every atom of our solar
system to every atom say Alpha Centauri
which is the closest star system Proxima
Centaur is the closest star so 4.3 light
years away so you have this bird speak
all these ropes coming out and they
eventually you know even though they
they don't merge they don't merge but
more of the ropes will go through the
center and fewer ones will go to the
outer side so the density of ropes forms
this bird's beak and what happens is you
know at some point you only have a
sensory like a straight line there's no
gravity between
uh Alpha Centauri and uh and uh our Sun
or the Earth if you want uh during in
the bird speak I'm sorry in the linear
regime and so whenever you hit the
linear regime you're going to go slow
because you have nothing pulling on you
you're simply drifting along you know
all the ropes through the ropes just
eternally you know looking at ropes
coming you don't see them but they're
coming into your atoms and out the back
and you're just sliding like you would
be sliding on like a little ball on the
Abacus that's that's how you would be
going but there's no gravity you don't
have this um 9.8 meters per second
square that we have here on Earth where
you fall from the sky you go fast that
doesn't happen between once you hit the
linear regime from from that point on to
uh Proxima Centauri you will not get
that pull okay and so you travel slow uh
that's one issue and so you travel
internally almost because that's how
slow it is let alone even if you could
travel at the speed of light 4.3 uh I'm
sorry 300 000 kilometers per second you
would reach Alpha centaurium 4.3 years
one way
yeah
nobody's ever going to do that assuming
we could travel even at the speed of
light which ain't possible
so all these people are talking nonsense
when they talk about extraterrestrials
and seeing UFOs meaning extraterrestrial
UFOs if there's some Gadget from here on
Earth yeah that's that's no biggie but
if you really think that the ETS are
here and that they made the pyramids and
that they made the Nazca Lines over
there in Peru and so on all that is bunk
nonsense poppycock you should move on
with your life and do something better
you're just wasting your time now if you
just want to fantasize that's good no
problem if you want to watch a a
Hollywood movie on extraterrestrials I I
watch them too but to bring those into
the real world
and believe that they're here
uh you need 10 more beers you need to
get out of that
okay let's move on to the subject matter
of today and that's gonna be uh what the
holographic universe
but before we can get to the holographic
Universe I got to talk about uh subject
an introduction to it
um
related to related to the holographic
universe and it is this word field
what in the world is a field and some
people believe that field is a physical
object okay and then this fellow raised
the issue and uh
so what I can do is just try to answer
his questions uh but uh it starts with
with uh an article that came out okay
and it says is the universe a hologram
okay and here it is okay uh Scientific
American uh is your universe is our
universe a hologram and so they're
celebrating lately right the 25th
anniversary of someone creating this
holographic Universe okay and again we
have to go first and look at a field to
understand what a field is before we can
go into the word uh into the holographic
Universe because as you will see they're
related in fact the word field and the
word energy cannot be stripped out of
mathematical physics meaning out of the
mouths of everybody out there everybody
talks in terms of feels and energy and
they don't have the slightest clue what
they're talking about and they treat
these words as physical objects okay so
here's this uh this uh fellow and he
says the following this is what got me
started on this thingy okay he said you
say only physical threads make any sense
well no I'm not saying that they they're
the only ones that make any sense I'm we
make an assumption and we say okay let
us assume that there are ropes out there
beta threads two point threads and uh
based on that assumption assumption
right uh you create your theories you
found your uh uh theories on those
assumptions that's the way the
scientific method works okay that fields
are only Concepts absolutely field is a
concept it's not a physical object you
can't use it as a baseball bat you
cannot use it as a thing to move things
along or to interface with things and
this is what this poor fellow doesn't
understand your ropes are said to be
physical right yeah physical physical
means object thing that's what fizzings
they're synonyms okay it's an entity all
these words are synonyms what is
physical that which has shape
okay that's the definition of physical
ropes have shape if you don't believe me
you go to your uh local uh hardware
store ask for a two-strand rope and
it'll give you something that looks more
or less like this okay and this is a
thing can you see the shape okay it has
shape Okay so
uh ropes have shape and what we're
saying is that the light and gravity are
mediated by an entity that has the
appearance of a two-strand rope twine
two strand rope like DNA like object
that's what we're saying that's our
proposal that's our assumption okay so
we showed the object we're saying it's
an object because it has shape and we're
going to use it to explain gravity and
light okay that's that's how it works
okay well this fellow said well field is
also physical
well
no it's not and the problem here is that
he hasn't defined physical he doesn't
know what the word physical means and he
hasn't defined it and the problem there
also is that you know if you say look
you got to Define these words he'll say
oh you're doing word wizard or you're
you're doing ontology you're doing um
stuff that has nothing to do with
physics
that's the way they look at it they for
them the word enters in one ear and
comes out the other because there's
nothing in between to stop it okay
there's nothing there and uh yeah you
got a problem because if you think that
a field is a thing if you think that a
field is physical
you think it's an object then you got
real problems okay so we have to
determine the words here because science
is 150 percent word Wizardry word salad
uh ontology semantics any of those words
that you dismiss as oh uh that's
nonsense we don't care about words yeah
we do in science we do because we have
to make ourselves understood to the
person who's listening okay we need to
understand what your theory is we won't
understand it if you don't Define these
terms so uh when he says it's physical
he's not saying anything because he
hasn't told us what physical means in
his world in his little mind okay you
can call it whatever makes you happy I
don't care he thinks it's a question of
naming it well you can call it Susie if
you want you can call it Peter you know
Johnny what name would you like to call
it it's not a question of names it's a
question what does field mean what does
it stand for it stands for a concept not
for an object
a field is a concept an abstract concert
it's a mathematical concept these people
say no no I see something around the
magnet and it moves the iron filing so
it's physical
yeah see and touch are not the criteria
for an object shape is the criteria to
Define an object so they think that
because something moved the iron filing
that's something they call field and
they say oh it's an object it's a thing
it's a wet physical
and then he says you can't deny its
existence
well you can't use the word existence
which belongs exclusively to physics
until you define it
okay and it Concepts don't even don't uh
exist you cannot say that a concept
exists in physics love does not exist
okay uh
data or information does not exist okay
you can't say that Concepts is conscious
does not exist you cannot use the word
exist with Concepts
you can only use it with objects in
physics and physics is the signs of
existence okay so the word existence the
word object those two words belong
exclusively of physics they don't belong
to philosophy they don't belong to any
other discipline they belong exclusively
to physics so someone says God exists I
don't care you step the line over into
physics now he's in physics if he says
exists okay now he's got to explain what
he means by exist and uh and then we can
follow his presentation otherwise if he
says God exists or God doesn't exist we
have no idea what he said until he
defines the word exists let alone the
word God right so yeah yeah this fellow
thinks that it's uh field is physical
and that it exists and we're going to
say that no to both those uh Notions
that this poor fellow has he was
brainwashed by maybe the people at the
electric universe or Walter Russell or
Tesla or one of those bozos you know
okay so here we go
um yeah we have uh field is it an object
well these are this is the rundown okay
physical means thing object entity all
those are the same words okay in physics
and something that which has shape okay
so all these words are the same whether
you say physical thing object entity
something anything all those words mean
exact all those words mean exactly the
same thing okay field that which has
shape
is does a field have shape and the
answer is no field does not have shape
and among the uh things that these
people never realize is that field is
alleged to be infinite
they say the field extends forever okay
so if a field extends forever it's
infinite as a mathematician would say
then obviously it does not have shape
you cannot draw for me a field because
you're saying it's infinite and if not
you got to tell me where it stops and
what the field looks like
and so these people want to do something
else they say look the field moved the
iron filing so it touched it and so
because there's touch it's got to be an
object
that's your rationale if you can call it
rational
no absolutely not
an object that which has shape not that
which you touch or that something can
touch you know the Moon is not an object
because the asteroid touched it you know
crashed against it
no the moon was an object before the
asteroid touched it and why was it an
object because it had shape not because
it can be seen or touched
okay so let's get that one right okay
and again the field extends forever
field is a concept an abstract
mathematical concept what does it mean
it value at each point in space what are
they talking about they're talking about
numbers and units that's what a field is
numbers and units was created by Mr
Faraday this word around 1845 and he
published uh he gave a dissertation in
1850 and then he published that District
teacher in 1851 where he defines the
word field
so what is a field
well field is a region
field is a region region of value
strengths of different kind it could be
magnetic strength could be gravitational
strength field is a region of strengths
and what they do is they have a value at
each point in space right in that region
and uh closer to the object the thing is
stronger the field is stronger the
numbers increase and farther away they
decrease that's what a field is a bunch
of numbers
you can't say a bunch of numbers moves
this it moves that it cannot interface
with anything a bunch of numbers is a
concept okay and so it's irrational say
that a concept exists in physics so you
can't so phys so field is not an object
not a thing and then you cannot say it
it exists because the concepts cannot be
said to exist in physics it has to be an
object okay so these are the things that
this fellow never learned uh wherever he
studied okay the monastery okay uh here
it is uh his theory is
um essentially that a field moves things
touches things moves iron found so he
says it's a thing because it interfaced
with the iron file and he had moved it
it put it in the right position or it
moved the charge
or in case of gravity you know it
attracts you to the Earth so there's
something there called the field that is
doing something to you it's interfacing
with you it's touching you
okay and so what this felt is saying
essentially is that you know you have a
concept
such as love okay
and uh so people say hey love moves
mountains
love moves mountains well maybe that's
very poetic that's good stuff for poetry
maybe maybe literature you know uh but
you can't use that in physics you can't
say love moves mountains literally in
physics okay and uh so this is his
theory okay he's saying that love moves
mountains okay he's gonna move a
mountain with love
uh this is how he does the field thingy
okay so uh you're saying that a field
meaning this concept is going to move in
Iron filing how do you do that I mean if
it's like love moving a mountain a
concept that's trying to interface with
a thing okay
okay
um
here we have the Earth's gravitational
field and what does that feel well you
can see that the numbers decrease as you
go further and further away from the
earth that's uh how we look at it if you
weigh a hundred kilograms on the surface
of the Earth the farther you go out the
less you weigh okay and what does that
mean well that's the gravitational field
that according to the mathematicians
extends forever okay
forever means it doesn't have shape this
field thingy and all we have is just
values that are decreasing with distance
the greater the distance the lower the
value that's what a field is just a
bunch of numbers that decrease uh in a
region whatever region you choose to
chop off okay so that's our
gravitational field
how about the um magnetic field you know
here we have a magnetic field how far
does it extend for example the magnetic
field of the earth uh what are those
lines are they
um made of solid uh
iron or what you know I mean what are
those lines they draw them and these
people look at them and say oh yeah I
recognize that that's the field what do
you mean the field what is that what are
you staring at is is that some kind of
animal that's got all these hairs
pulling out of it
uh you know so so these people treat
these uh words as as things and uh in
the case of the magnetic field uh
everybody says it's an infinite magnetic
field and it extends forever okay since
uh it doesn't stop and so if it doesn't
stop it doesn't have shame and if it
doesn't have shape obviously it's not a
physical object according to our
definition now if you don't like the
definition no problem all you have to do
is challenge it you know challenge it
and propose something that you can
defend defend your definition of what an
object is what a thing is you can't
defend it you don't have a case
okay so we are here we tell you what it
is a thing is that which has shape very
clear okay not a thing that you can a
thing is not that which you can see or
touch
which is what this uh fellow is running
with he's running informally with his
definition of seat touching he says
Fields touch things no they don't
because Concepts don't touch things love
does not move mountains okay
okay here we have uh Stevie Wonder uh
Stephen Hawking you know and he comes up
with his idea of what a field is he
gives you an idea here okay he says the
far he says there must be certain
minimum amount of uncertainty or Quantum
fluctuations in the value of the field
and uh he's gonna eventually use this to
uh for his you know holographic Universe
his uh black holes his
um his notion of you know how this
universe runs so he's going to use this
word field you can also use the word
energy which is another undefined word
right and treat it as a physical object
and say oh the energy we transferred the
energy oh yeah one can think of these
fluctuations as pairs of particles of
light or gravity that appear together at
some time move apart then come together
again and annihilate each other okay so
we have particles they can go apart
right these particles that they call
virtual particles then they come back
they form a single particle then they
bunch of uh you know they separate again
and uh one thing that can do that is a
black hole The Event Horizon you know
half of the particle falls in the other
a half travels to your eyes you know
that's a Hawking radiation right these
particles are virtual particles what's a
virtual particle uh it's an ad hoc
so-called particle not even a corpuscle
but uh that the mathematicians invented
because they could not explain what's
happening in that invisible World in
which they uh the they run their
experiments right these particles are
virtual particles like the particles
that carry the gravitational force
he's gonna have uh these gravitational
particles that carry the force right and
he says they're virtual in other words
these particles appear and disappear
constantly you know so they can't really
measure or detect them
so they're unseeable untouchable
okay so even there you would not be able
to use the definition they're unseeable
and Untouchable they appear whenever the
mathematician needs them ad hoc and they
disappear when he doesn't need them
anymore ad hoc again
and they call them virtual particles
which ain't particles anyways they're
just values that they have to put in the
comp in the equation to make the
equation come out right so they say well
something happened here that we don't
have in our equation I just put a
variable in there we'll call it a
virtual particle so much value and then
it leans again for that Split Second we
have a particle out of nowhere you know
God sent it
particles that carry gravitational force
of the sun unlike real particles which
ain't particles either right because
those are numbers as well they cannot be
observed directly with a particle
detector in other words these are ad hoc
thingies that they invent and they form
this field that uh they're going to use
gravitational field magnetic field
electric field they're going to use it
all with particles which ain't particles
which are virtual particles which ain't
particles either none of these are
particles okay they're not corpuscle
they're just numbers that they put in
there we're talking about Concepts not
things okay however they're indirect
effects because they can't do it
directly so they do it indirectly such
as the small changes in the energy of
electron orbits in atoms can be measured
so they're measuring the electron
they're saying something happens there
and we think it's caused by this virtual
particle that appears whenever it wants
to and leaves whenever it wants to where
does it come from the vacuum so the
vacuum is made of these virtual
particles that are buzzing in there okay
the vacuum is not vacuum it's uh full of
not even full of it's made of particles
let's get that right okay they're saying
the vacuum is made of these balls
we don't know what's between these balls
because if it's a little ball right a
little grain of sand it's got to have
something distinguish it from the next
screen of sand you know the neighbor
so it's not one grain of Sands two
grains of sand there's got to be
something dividing them what's that
something well they never figured it out
they just say these particles come in
from the void because they make up the
void right and again all these particles
are making up the void that's what
they're saying so when you pull one in I
guess it leaves a hole behind but does
it leave behind another space I mean I
don't know they have to figure this out
anyways here it is
um
this is a field okay and I want you to
see this because when you have when you
have a field what is a field
we're saying that a field is a bunch of
threads that are magnetic field right a
bunch of threads that are spinning
around the atoms okay and so that's a
field field has to do with all these
threads that are swinging around the
atoms that's region of what we call
magnetic field has something that's
moving in there the field itself is the
region but there is an object there that
is moving inside that region that's the
one we have to locate okay and here and
let me give you a um a little simulation
what I'm talking about look at this okay
we have the little girl okay her name is
Susie and she's skipping a rope okay now
uh we have a rope and we have that red
region and we will call that a field
that's the field of the Rope that's the
extent where the Rope is moving okay now
what happens field is the region the red
part and a rope is something else the
Rope is the thing that's moving inside
that region so we have the field and we
have the object field is a concept okay
it's just a region Region's a static
concept now someone throws a uh stone at
Susie it turns out it doesn't hit her
because something prevented uh the Stone
from hitting
um Susie so what was it was it the field
or was it the rope that hit that stone
that you know that prevented the Sun
from hitting uh Susie
again was it again here field we have
the Rope okay and here she goes okay
someone tries to throw a uh Stone in her
okay or several stones and as soon as he
they the stone gets near her something
hits it okay something strange is it the
field or is it the Rope
can you say that the field is what hit
the uh the uh Stone
okay so this is the same situation with
uh with the uh
uh magnet magnetic field magnetic field
has something twirling inside it
something moving in there okay that's
the one that moves the iron filings and
all this other good stuff it's not it's
not the field the field is the whole
region of numbers so the field is a
concept you can't see the field does
this or the field does that you cannot
put an article in front of the word
field you can have say a field or the
field
it's irrational in physics that's okay
in ordinary speech you can talk like
that over there no problem in irrational
language nobody bothers but in physics
you cannot put an article in front of
the word field because it's not a
physical object you can only put
articles in front of object you can say
the chair the tree the rock you can say
it like that and here we have to say in
this case we say the thread thread is an
object and the thread is moving okay and
the region in which it moves that's the
concept the abstract concept the region
known as field a bunch of numbers it
just says it's stronger over here and
weaker over there that's all we're
saying with the word field okay because
field is not a thing it's that it
doesn't have shape especially if it's an
infinite field if it stretches all the
way to the eternity well then it cannot
have shape and therefore it doesn't even
qualify under our definition and it
doesn't qualify under the C touch
definition because the field is not
hitting the stone what's hitting the
stone is whatever is twirling inside the
field region okay we got that okay so
here we have a good old Faraday who
confirms what I just said he says I
cannot conceive curved lines of force
without the conditions of a physical
existence in that intermediate space
okay you wrote that in 1852 and good old
Max Maxwell he says field the space in
the neighborhood of the electric and
magnetic bodies in that space in that
region right there is matter in motion
something is moving in the region in the
concept and the numerical concept right
called field
so field is not an object something is
moving inside the field and what you got
to identify is that something you cannot
say that uh
um you know what's What's Happening Here
is that uh the field is is doing
something no field cannot do anything
but it's not a thing
okay
so um here we have uh
proof of that okay uh he said there's
something moving inside the field and
I've shown this before here we showed it
one more time so that everybody can kill
their ignorance something is moving
inside the field okay that's what I'm
saying that's what Maxwell says uh
Faraday is saying the same thing these
guys worked a lot with magnets something
people today don't do they just repeat
whatever the the the teachers or the
professors teach them or you know
whatever they learned by wrote and here
it is okay here's a magnet underwater
and you can see the iron valleys are
picked up one at a time Slowly by
something that is moving that region of
water which we call a field field is the
water okay is the the region and
something is moving inside that
invisible region and that invisible
something has the ability to move iron
filings around you can see the iron
filings are coming slowly to the magnet
it's not like they all you know it's not
a static thing where you know they're
already there it's pulling one at a time
something is moving in there we're
saying it's the threads that come out of
uh extend from the magnet itself from
the atoms that make up the uh
the magnet
okay so we have this magnet the threads
are moving around and because of that
they're interfacing with uh iron file
needs the nuggets and pulling them in
one at a time so this is in slow motion
right but you can imagine you know uh
the weather is good really because it
slows it down if you did it you know out
here it would go bring all the iron
Founders together you would probably not
notice anything you put your magnet
underwater you'll see that they're
picked up slowly slower than you know
out here in air and so uh that's the
issue the issue is that uh in in water
you can see it slowly and you will see
that something is drawing one uh nugget
at a time
okay something is moving in that region
Maxwell said there's something in Motion
in that region we call speed field okay
so we got that part
moving on here okay so uh we're gonna
relate this now to the uh holographic
universe and I gotta give you another
introduction another subject to to be
able to get to the famous holographic
Universe here's the uh Circle okay now
everybody said okay I've seen that
before in geometry and unfortunately I
have to go through this uh little basic
stuff you know uh just so you see how uh
how these people think okay it's we're
going to see how a mathematician thinks
okay and how irrationally he thinks
really okay here it is you want to
calculate the circumference of the um of
that Circle and it's 2 pi uh R okay 2R
means two radius in other words you have
diameter there and you multiply the
radius times two and you get the
diameter it turns out the diameter fall
fits into the circle about three times a
little over three times
um where did we get this well we get it
from here you can take
um a circumference or a circle right you
open it up
here it is starts in a second there he
goes and so you unroll it and that's
more or less what you're going to get
three three and fourteen right
and this is how the Greeks really
figured it out they figured that out uh
uh
pragmatic you know doing the experiment
some kind of experiment they said okay
if it's three and a half three three and
uh Point fourteen times uh you just
unroll the circle that's essentially it
or the circumference okay so
um that part they figured out you know
very early then uh came uh more ideas on
you know if you wanted to calculate
something like you know you want to
calculate the area of a circle and here
they said okay here's your you have the
circle which Again by the way the circle
is a plane that means that the
circumference is not a uh is not the
circle the circle is the whole plate
okay
and uh so what is the how do you
calculate this well here it is you want
to figure out the surface of a circle
they eventually figured out that it's uh
pi times r squared okay so if you
multiply the radius squared times the
uh Pi 314 right you get the um the
surface of a circle okay so this this
was their line of thinking okay they
started with a circle with the
circumference they opened it up they
said 314 that's the ratio between
diameter and circumference then from
there they said what if we wanted to
calculate the surface
of a circle well
not you saw it there okay now here's the
area of a circle how it fits uh from a
physical point of view you can say okay
let me roll it here here it goes
you can see it opens it up okay if you
take that area one way of calculating it
right and you open up the um the circle
okay and you do these fancy things on
the triangle you can figure out the area
and that's pretty much has to measure
match the surface of a uh of a circle
okay you can see how they more or less
do it okay so you can prove it to
yourself if you want but I just want you
to see the line of thinking here for now
they went from circumference to Circle
then they said what if we want the area
right okay they were figuring these
things out then they went to this they
said what if we have a steer right and
they eventually figured out that the
volume of a sphere is four thirds pi R
cubed okay so if you want to know what
the volume is of a uh of a ball right a
perfect ball right ideal ball well you
just apply that formula see how simple
it is and and uh you know just have to
find out what the radius is and it'll
give you an idea of uh you know what the
volume is
okay here we go um with uh this this is
essentially what they do when they try
to figure out the volume they simply put
layer upon layer upon layer until they
reach the radius okay of the sphere so
this is what they have in the backs of
their minds it's nested layers nested
spheres okay if you put one inside the
other 11 should end up with the volume
of the whole sphere
okay and there's a neat little trick to
find out
um
you know if you want to turn your uh
volume
into the surface you want to calculate
the surface area
of the sphere so you have this you know
you have this volume in the sphere right
and there you had the equation and if
you want to calculate the surface now of
that sphere well they figured out how to
do that as well and here let me show you
how they do a nice little trick so that
way you can learn a little derivatives
and uh calculus you'll be an expert
after today okay this is this is what
they do okay this is the notion okay
what you have is you have the volume of
a sphere and what you do you take that 3
you put it up front okay and you
subtract one from the two from the three
they're from the r Cube you went to r
squared let me show that one more time
okay here it is you start out with four
thirds pi R cubed the three from the
cube goes to two and becomes a
multiplier
one more time
okay here it goes
okay look at that three goes out turns
into a two and then the two threes
cancel out and there you have four pi r
squared and that is the surface area
that that will give you the value of the
surface area of a uh of a sphere okay so
you have the volume we have a way of
calculating that and you have the
surface area
Bill why did you go through all this
nonsense I didn't come here to learn
math I came here and learned physics
okay because our holographic Universe
has to do with what you just saw that's
why the idea the notion they have is
that the surface area
okay of a black hole right
um is uh coded uh in other words it
codes the information that's inside a
black hole
and the notion is that our universe is
like a black hole they're trying to
figure that out and they're saying well
maybe we're inside a black hole meaning
a sphere right and if we can figure out
you know what's on the surface we can
code that and find out what's on the
inside of the universe and if that's the
case well then you have this holographic
Universe which is a way of looking at
the how a to the surface they call it 2D
it's not really 2D but they call it a 2d
surface projects it's um or or is a
measure of how much information is
inside that ball okay so why why did
they do this well because now you're
you're putting a little bit of
Relativity which is the black hole part
right and you're trying to figure out
you know uh how we can use some geometry
some regular stuff
um and see if we can merge quantum
mechanics with uh relativity Okay so so
that's the point that's why that's why I
Strength that's how the string theory
came to be and that's why strengtheory
is still alive and well because they're
trying to figure out gravity they're
trying to figure it out from the 2D
surface how it's projected onto the 3D
volume of a black hole that's their
starting point and then they're going to
extrapolate that and say well the
universe is also holographic and they
use the turn of holographic because you
know what is a hologram hologram is a 3D
projection of a to the surface okay so
that's where the word that's how they
put these things together and again it's
got to do with their line of reasoning
okay they they're always trying to
calculate things they're saying I want
to calculate uh circumference I want to
calculate the uh Circle the the
surface area of a circle I'm going to
calculate the volume of a of a ball I
want to calculate you know the surface
area of a ball and when they go through
this whole thing they say oh by the way
you know it turns out that a black hole
is a ball it's a perfect ball right
because it's set to all this it was a
star right that collapsed gravitational
only upon itself or so they say and
because it's got this region of
influence which we'll call the surface
the surface of the black hole and
they're gonna say look if you want to
know what's inside the black hole you
know all the information that's in there
hey you just got to look at the surface
because that's that's what the surface
is it's a it codes whatever information
is inside the black hole okay so this is
their line of reasoning that's why all
this is tied together okay okay so here
we have a black hole okay it looks more
or less like that think of it as a
sphere okay black sphere and again it's
important to note that uh that's not
totally true what you really have is a
singularity
um in the center and the black stuff is
really a region of influence that they
call the Event Horizon okay so you have
the little dot in the center which
unfortunately you know I have to
apologize I wasn't able to make it Zero
Dimensional uh I tried all night to make
it Zero Dimensional and I always kept
getting at least two D's so no matter
how hard I tried you know I guess I'm
not a good artist but maybe you can try
it in at home you know always in the
presence of a relativist and try to see
if you can draw Zero Dimensional
singularity
anyways this uh that's what's in the
center there okay here we have uh let's
get rid of the words okay so
um so you so you have this you have a
little dot in the center which is a
singularity you have that uh surface
right the red uh lying around it's the
red circumference right uh but it's
really you got to think of it as a cross
section there because what you're really
looking at is the whole covering of the
sphere
and at Hope covering you know the whole
sphere is really the black hole or the
extent of the black hole you got to
think of it like this think of it as a
uh what is it a campfire so the Little
Dot in the center is the campfire and
the region of influence is you know you
have heat from the campfire well the
region of influence is how far does the
heat go where it has some kind of effect
and so you know you're you're not in the
center of the campfire you're somewhere
far away and you can still feel the heat
of the campfire and this is more or less
the same thing an analogy for that here
you have the little dot in the center
which is supposed to be Zero D and the
region of influence gravitational
influence where uh gravity travels at
the speed of light right is up to that
red uh Circle that's going around it the
circumference okay so this is the notion
of a black hole
okay so uh what's the issue the issue is
we're going to try to calculate the
volume of that sphere and uh what we
have on the outside is the surface area
and they say you know you use that
equation and you're going to figure out
you know uh how big the black hole is
okay and they can do this uh with mass
they see it's got so much mass so the
volume of the sphere of the Event
Horizon right from the singularity all
the way to the edge of the Event Horizon
right uh you can calculate not only the
volume but you can calculate also the
surface area that encapsulates that
volume okay and of course if more matter
Falls in well then what you have is a
bigger black hole supposedly a bigger
Event Horizon right it expands and you
have to do a new calculation for that
new expansion but the point here is that
what they're trying to tell you is that
all the information oh really I hate to
use the word information because they're
saying that information travels okay and
again we're we're moving Concepts here
okay make sure you understand that but
they say any particle any atom that
falls into the black hole is sucked
together all the way to the center of
the black hole to the same angularity
okay so now that little particle right
goes all the way to the singularity and
disappears it's crushed out of existence
what remains is its mass okay and
um
because now the mass is greater the uh
Event Horizon now has expanded by so
much and so by studying how much surface
area the
um uh the black The Event Horizon has
right it codifies it it tells us
something about what's inside the or the
information that was put into as they
cause certain information that is inside
the black hole it's got to do with this
word entropy okay they equate entropy
with
information okay so now we're we're away
from physics now we're going to talk
about information
entropy you know how much this order
there is how much uh information there
is inside the black hole whatever that
means you know how can you contain
information but this is what they talk
about so I can only go with what they're
saying okay I can't I'm just trying to
uh tell you what these people are
talking about that's all it's all
nonsense but we got to start somewhere
okay and here's Mr matto Dot and he this
is what he has to say the main part okay
he says a black holes entropy represents
the amount of quantum information of
everything that ever fell into it okay
so he's going to talk about information
he's not going to talk about things
anymore now he's going to talk about
this abstract concept called information
which they probably wouldn't be able to
Define and he's going to talk about how
how much order how much this order it
has entropy being the uh word used for
that concept okay this represents the
amount maximum possible entropy slash
information of any volume of space the
maximum is proportional to the surface
area of that space not its volume in
other words what they're saying is the
surface area is going to give you an
idea of how much entropy how much
information is in there something about
information that fell in there together
with the you know the particle that
carried that information the information
of all material that fell into the black
hole could be imprinted on the outgoing
Hawking radiation in other words you
have this Hawking radiation again
particles that split and one guy
leaves to your eye the other one Falls
in and essentially so they use these
virtual particles again ad hoc stuff to
explain these things well it's waiting
to be radiated this is interesting well
it's waiting to be radiated that
information should be encoded In the
Event Horizon so here you have this uh
information it's just waiting there
information is just standing there at
the Event Horizon we have nothing
sitting on nothing right we have
information sitting on an event horizon
okay and it's waiting to be radiated
still not radiated but well it's still
there we can study the black hole and
say okay all we got to look at is the
Event Horizon find out how much
information is sitting there right and
from that we can tell something about
what's inside the black hole the history
of what happened to that particle so to
speak that's the information
from the point of view of the outside
observers its continents are smeared
onto this 2D surface okay so the surface
is painted with all this information
from the point of view of anyone falling
in they are definitely inside the black
hole this is the first glimpse of a
holographic space-time a 2d surface that
encodes the properties of the 3D
interior
okay so so what any of this has to do
with physics I have no idea but uh I
hope you're getting the idea the idea is
that particles fall in right they form
part of that region called uh the uh
from The Singularity to the event
horizon Singularity is zero dementia
it's just the center of this whole thing
and contains essentially all the mass
you want you know as much mass as you
want and depending on how much mass that
Singularity has the Event Horizon has a
certain radius from that Singularity
okay so it gets bigger the the globe
gets bigger the the sphere gets bigger
the sphere of influence okay and so you
have the Event Horizon and on that event
horizon you have information that's just
sitting there just painting the walls of
the Event Horizon it's just sitting
there until it you know they give them
the order to to uh be irradiated out by
studying what's on the surface for that
Split Second or however time if it's in
eternity that it's just sitting there
you can tell something about the
particle that fell in which is the
information and so this is what they're
trying to convey to you that they can by
studying the surface of a black hole
they can tell you something about the
information the entropy right that's
inside the black hole okay and uh here
you have uh one uh article that
convinces you that what I just told you
has to do with our universe our universe
is holographic because it is like a
black hole you can treat it like a ball
and because remember the big bang you
know hopefully was quite symmetrical
space was expanding in all directions so
you would think we're talking about a
ball right so the universe is a ball
what's outside of it we don't know as we
talked about last week we don't know
what's outside because they say you
don't have to have an outside to a ball
to be able to conceptualize a ball or
visualize it right okay fine so we have
nothing outside the ball but the wall
has a radius okay and that radius is
expanding okay so here it is okay you
have is our universe a hologram these
people are trying to convince you that
it is much like a 3D hologram emerges
from in the information encoded on a 2d
surface our universe is 4D space-time
could be a holographic projection of a
lower dimensional reality okay so uh now
we've extrapolated our um our notion of
a black hole what what they study for
black home we say the universe is like
that as well because you know it's so
dark maybe we're inside a black hole you
know it's a sphere because you had big
bang and maybe the uh galaxies and the
stars are all scattered in different
directions but space
is quite symmetrical you would think you
know and all the galaxies are sitting on
the surface of this expanding Globe
which is space right and so yeah if you
treat it like that you say okay then I
can study the universe as a hologram
because all we have to do is find out
you know how it's encoded on the surface
of this thing we call Universe right
this ball
here's another one from Popular
Mechanics just to make sure that we
cover all the bases information is uh it
says black holes may be evidence okay so
they're looking for evidence right and
they also suggest that we are living in
a they say could be but they really mean
we are right living in a holographic
Universe information is the list of all
properties of all the particles that
fell into the black hole in other words
everything you need to reconstruct the
original objects that fell in one way to
measure the amount of information is
through entropy a thermodynamic concept
that is Loosely related to the amount of
disorder in a system
black holes have a surprising property
uh-huh which one is that their entropy
is proportional to their surface area
not to their volume in other words the
amount of information in a black hole is
related to its two-dimensional surface
not a three-dimensional volume which is
what you just said right hologram
encodes all three-dimensional
information in a two-dimensional surface
great so there appears to be something
funny about black holes wherein their
information seems to be encoded under
two dimensional surfaces perhaps the
same is true for what for the whole
entire universe
okay so what they've these people have
done they went from I mean if we look at
the history since the days of the Greeks
we went from circumference to circles to
spheres uh surface of circle surface of
the sphere then they say oh by the way
the black hole is a sphere okay so let's
put all this geometry that we learned in
uh High School let's put it into black
hole and they studied that they
developed equations and then they said
oh by the way we can create a hologram
uh and what is it it's a projection uh a
2d 2D source to a 3D Volume right so you
see the 3D object in front of you right
and they say oh by the way the universe
is also like a ball because you know it
expanded from The Big Bang right and so
we we probably can figure out you know
that the Universe works like a like a
black hole meaning holographically right
which means it encodes
the matter that's inside the universe
including the space I guess uh from the
surface of this expanding big bang
thingy space time right so this is their
notion this is how they're working this
whole thing but what's the problem here
well at least one of the problems that I
want you to carry with you today and
that is
um
you know uh here you have uh what would
happen inside a black hole if the
universe were like a black hole well the
black hole what does it do it pulls
everything inwards towards the center
okay so this is what it would look like
more or less okay you would see the
universe
right Contracting towards the
singularity okay that would be what we
would expect from a universe if it is
like a black hole and instead our
universe does the opposite it does
something like this okay it expands
hey our universe is said to be exploding
Big Bang is still exploding and so it's
not Contracting towards you know towards
a singularity
okay so uh these are the Notions these
people have for the universe
and of course a lot of his bunch of
nonsense both the expanding universe as
well as the uh holographic notion that
these people have in their minds they
have no idea how this universe works and
all they're doing is math because they
can apply the math to spheres right to
planes and they say we we know about
Holograms and uh turns out that we can
figure out what's going on inside a
black hole without going in there
because uh the information inside is
encoded on the outside on the surface of
this black hole Singularity the region
of influence stops at the Event Horizon
we just need to study the surface of the
Event Horizon which ain't a thingy it's
not a surface at all it's just a concept
it's like saying that the heat from a
campfire you know wherever it reaches
whenever it still burns your hand or
whatever uh you can say well it's a
thing
no no it's not a thing the heat is not a
thing heat is a concept okay the fact
that it touches your hand burns is a
process but to say that that whole
region where the heat is the field right
is a thing that you can take you can
carry with you somewhere no no it's not
a thing
but they treat it as a thing and if if
it applies to the black hole why not to
the universe if the universe is a ball
that's expanding with what's it got on
the surface uh you know this expanding
sphere what's got all the galaxies all
the planets because remember it's not
it's not in the volume that we're in
we're on the surface of the universe
that's expanding and pushing on Galaxies
apart and stars Etc right so keep in
mind what they're saying they're saying
that the universe is a ball and all we
need to do is study what's on the
surface that's where we're at you know
we're we're all on Surface and it gives
us an idea of what's going to be inside
meaning all the way to the The
Singularity meaning all the way to Big
Bang talk about the holographic Universe
well that's what it's all about
okay a couple questions uh fellow says
says physics is math ever since it's uh
it divorced itself from natural
philosophy that was in the 17th century
they used to call it natural philosophy
then uh they went off
really started even in the 16th century
because you had people like William
Gilbert and Stevens in Holland and other
people uh maletti in Italy you know
these people ran experiments and they
already and he obviously did math and so
they started doing a little math a
little experiments and eventually the
thought came out that you know Aristotle
was wrong he was just doing philosophy
supposedly you know he was just doing
things thinking that this the way the
universe works when it didn't work that
way and the main point there is uh that
he never figured out that uh you know
two stones of different weights fall at
the same rate uh or same time to the
Earth and that was the people in the
16th century before Galileo by the way
Stebbins already in uh what was it 15
um 76 I think it was when uh Galileo was
still uh running around in uh shorts
he was a baby uh Stevens already had
done his experiment in Holland with two
stones he wrote about that in in his
book
um where he talks about mechanics and he
already had done the experiment from a
big tower and just found that Aristotle
was wrong that two stones do fall at the
same time he did it with a wooden thing
at the bottom so that the stones would
make a noise he said they made they both
well at the same time they did the
experiment several times and he wrote
about it so Galileo did not invent that
but all these bosses they just pass on
the word Galileo did Galileo's the guy
who proved it okay anyways physics only
cares about practical applications
anyways technology now that's not
physics okay the fact that they call it
physics is uh is a misnomer okay they're
not doing physics in fact they're not
even doing uh
uh you know
anything that's related to our real
world they're talking about Concepts
abstract Concepts like field and energy
and they say we move the field we move
the energy we bend the time you know
that's how they talk and all that talk
is gibberish because it's all Concepts
they're not talking about moving objects
they cannot visualize their theories
their explanations you know they're um
the mechanics of how the word world How
the Universe works mechanistically okay
and and another question here uh thing
same guy he says in the invisible action
at a distance a pull is irrational
well that's just a statement uh
hasn't explained anything he doesn't say
why he thinks it's irrational he
probably wouldn't be able to define the
word irrational okay you cannot Define
the word irrational we do Define the
word rational irrational right
irrational when you move a concept okay
and so if you're pulling with a rope
you're not doing anything irrational
okay you if you pull on a horse with a
rope we can all rationalize that we can
all visualize it you can make a movie of
it and you say okay I understood the
mechanism the mechanism is he pulls on a
rope and the horse or the doctor he
comes towards the farmer right we all
understand that but if he goes like that
you know and he says what do you pulling
with well I'm pulling with one kilogram
well that doesn't make any sense I'm
pulling with energy I'm pulling with a
field what do you mean a field what kind
of field are you pulling with you know
so it's when you use Concepts that's
when you are irrational but as long as
you put a an object there and say you've
pulled on uh the horse with a rope or a
wire or an extended object of some kind
hey everybody can understand it and it's
rational because you can make an
illustration of it okay
gravity does not pull on anything okay
yeah gravity is a concept so I guess it
doesn't cool uh you have to explain how
the Earth pulls on a rock so you got to
talk earth rock or something along you
need to use objects when you talk in
physics can't say gravity gravity is a
concept gravity is what we're trying to
explain so you can't say gravity pulls
what happens when you open a container
that is under vacuum or with much lower
air pressure than its surroundings aha
what happens doesn't the surrounding air
rush into the container until pressures
are equalized yeah the Venturi effect
describes yeah it describes it doesn't
explain you haven't explained why the
cause the mechanism of why the air
rushes in
that's what you got to explain you can't
say it does yeah we know it does
the question is how do you do it how
does Mother Nature do that magic trick
how does it pull
that particle in there okay and yeah
I've interior is just a description we
want an explanation of the Venturi okay
how do you velocity of a fluid increases
as the cross-section of the container it
flows in decreases
Etc et cetera right the energy in this
increased speed comes by and again it
uses words such as energy
uses field he uses Venturi he doesn't
know how to explain he doesn't
understand physics physics is about
explaining the mechanism now
you know I work with a vacuum uh quite a
bit several years and you have a
very quickly here a rotoru vein pump
okay mechanical pump and it's a roughing
pump what is called a roughing Pump It
pumps a vacuum chamber it pulls you know
particles out of there out of the vacuum
chamber and it does it with a rotary
vein the vein just moves and the
particles go through a little hole right
a little opening and the rotary vein
pushes that particle along the uh inside
of the pump
and why doesn't that party go back go
back out because you're pushing it out
of another Outlet so it pulls it from
the vacuum chamber and out to the other
uh to to the outlet
and the question here is why does a
particle go in why don't particles come
out
you know that's what you got to explain
why do particles go from a uh region of
lower vacuum uh lower uh pressure to one
of higher pressure
I'm sorry the other higher pressure to
lower pressure why why do the particles
keep going inside the rotary vein
what's pulling in them there
why do particles tend to expand and
cover the room gas for example right or
why do uh particles inside them for
example in a gas inside a balloon why do
they push up against the balloon you got
to tell me the why what happens in there
why would they why I mean we know it
does so you can you can say well you
know we know that if we introduce air or
some gas inside a balloon it expands
great we all know this so you haven't
told us anything that we already know
the question is why why if you push air
in there does it push the balloon
outwards why don't the particles
concentrate all in the center and a
balloon just stays there
that's the question you got to answer
okay why do they push up against the
Rubber and and pushing outwards to make
this typical balloon the the sphere or
whatever
so it's the how the the house we know we
say well venturity thing every time you
do this uh particles go uh from here to
there
you have not explained the mechanism how
does it pull particles in there
that's what you got to explain until you
can explain the cause you haven't
explained absolutely anything so to say
oh I know because the Venturi effect and
he's trying to say that gravity works by
the Venturi effect well let me tell you
something Venturi effect does not work
uh out there with the Earth if you take
the Earth
uh you if if you were to go out there
you know uh like an Astron maybe without
a thingy in your head you know you can
go out there into into the atmosphere
and you'll find air that atmosphere is
air the farther away you go the less air
you find and at some point there is no
air in other words the air pressure is
higher on the earth because it's all
around this globe this sphere we call
earth right more or less a sphere except
if you're a flat earther
uh you have all this these molecules of
air you know surrounding the earth and
they get lighter and lighter there's
fewer and fewer of them as you go out at
some point there's no more air
and the question is where's your Venturi
effect when we need it why doesn't this
air go out why does it stay around the
Earth
what is this gravity thingy that's
pulling each air molecule towards the
center of the earth that's what you got
to answer the cause the mechanism don't
tell me the Venturi effect and Cherry
effect doesn't work when you look at the
Earth and and the air that's surrounding
it you got to tell me why why one
molecule of Air does not fly out of out
of the earth and go I don't know to Mars
or whatever
why does that particle stay
uh faithful to the Earth to the Center
of the Earth what Venturi effect are you
going to put for that single molecule
one molecule forget about all the others
I just need one molecule of air or one
atom if you want whichever that's what
you gotta answer
we'll see you next week
bye bye